I mean you just say this kid came up and
give me a hug it's like it's like that
non-stop it's like people just give me
love it's like you know everywhere I go
as people just are loving on me and it's
like they're acknowledging me and it's
interesting it's interesting because I
never wanted or really cared about it or
tried you know it just happened and it's
like and it's personified in the fact
that you don't see me in my video I mean
but yeah I'm so recognizable it's it's
all interesting stuff and I you know it
makes me think you know
and I it blows me away I didn't want
this or care about it and yet here it is
and and it goes to the fact that I made
myself the best myself an effective
vessel of the universe and a servant
servant for my fellow man and because I
did that powerful things happen
[Music]
amount of opportunities
though that would remember we're talking
about the movie yeah they just told me
that it's happening they're like I'm
going to comic-con and I'm gonna do some
promotion for it so like I was surprised
I thought it got to a point where it's
like oh that's not gonna happen and then
I hear like publicity publicist is
calling me and saying okay this is going
on this is what you need to say it's
like so so what's going on is they're
gonna make it into a future length
blockbuster movie with like big stars
yeah so like they said you can't say
who's gonna be but but but yeah we have
you know we've got Ben greenlight it and
it's a go and we're gonna start getting
capacity on it that's interesting cuz it
should be fun I mean I got to hang out
with fellow youtubers and it was you
know fun doing all the work and you know
being on saying all that it's all it's
all
[Music]
now when we did the trip when we did the
trailer it was a low-budget thing I mean
so but I imagine I've been on some
shoots and it's like yeah that's what
it's like you know it's really fun and
you got someone taking care of you the
whole time pop right it's like just like
this poor farmer yeah it's fun stuff
[Music]
I do use the thing powerful content is
going to come all the time I mean if you
make something really amazing it doesn't
matter what you do it's going to come
out so if you if you're just if you're
just creating content and you're
passionate about it and you're good in
your town you're interesting it will
happen it helps to market it helps to
network you have to do all that stuff
but it's not everything
it sounds like take time to look
[Music]
yeah but I see other people are doing it
because they want someone to see their
stuff I'm only doing it because they
want me to see their spell so it's
different for me because I'm not I don't
care about other people watching my
stuff I mean I like it and they tell me
they want to but that's not why I do it
I do it because they want that I'm
serving me that's the difference between
me and I'm doing it for everyone else
not for me and they're doing it because
they want to be famous they want people
to see who they are it's kind of a
backward thing for me I'm different
but I mean the reason why I spent so
much time coming in services people they
talk to me
go looking for other people's videos or
something like that it's the only one
they said it took me that I and I you
know that I even know it's there
like to all these big youtubers and
stuff now I don't
you know and I feel kind of weird being
here you know because like they're all a
little famous and they're figured I was
like there and they all know me yeah
yeah
okay we met a little girl on the train
and
getting started doing
she travel
what advice would you give to
[Music]
right so I what what I do is I don't
want
any of this what I do is I do what I'm
passionate about I do what I share my
life and I'm open and honest about it so
if people if people shared with people
shared themselves if they gave their
heart to the camera to the community I
think that's powerful that's that's what
people are drawn to so just give give up
yourself and don't do because you want
to be rich or famous or you know what I
mean do it because you're passionate
about it and you love it and you're
making your heart
is there any like
[Music]
but people that have been
I don't know about the don'ts but the
dues is like what and here's the thing I
broke all the rules you know I didn't I
mean it's it's different for me though
because I saw God and put a video put on
YouTube but everyone else it's work you
just you just got to work the community
you got to be friendly you got to go out
there and the bottom line is you got to
create content that's interesting and
people want to watch if you don't have
that then you can't do anything but on
top of that then you got to go to
network you've got a you know show it to
other people and it's it's all just work
it's not how I did it but I cheated
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's see I have such a different agenda
than everything that everyone else
because the people they're trying to
make a living on it they're trying to
get famous they're trying to get known
and that's not what I'm doing I mean I
am reporting myself from my descendants
and when you have that motivation it's
different than what other people with it
like almost every other YouTube they
always ask for people to subscribe to
them and all that never once done that I
don't care you know so I mean I break
all the rules but it's okay because I
have I have a different whole set of
thinking you know I don't I don't need
money I don't care about money you know
there's not there's not many people like
that so in that that's why this whole
thing came to me because I'm different
different than most people
well now you're speaking on it
yeah the panel is the rise of the viral
video yeah
yeah Saturday at 11 do you have any
things you can share all that or it's
gonna save it I'm I'm gonna well I'm
gonna be doing it with the people who
did the double rainbow summer the most
popular one and they're really awesome
and we're gonna be tough well most
likely we probably talk about what it's
like to be a meme and what created that
and all that and I mean I'm gonna be
just saying all this stuff which is like
I think I'm not I'm not what other
people are doing
I'm just doing something different
works for me
what meme ME ME it's an it's an it's an
idea that spreads to humanity like a
virus
I've found that
yeah well I mean you know if there's
things that you just know about you know
like things in in society or things in
in humanity's consciousness that's like
oh I just know that you know I mean this
you don't know how you know it it's just
everywhere you know and everyone kind of
knows that so I mean I don't have any
examples of it but I know there's I mean
if I brought him up you'd be like oh
yeah I know that you know I mean so it's
just like I could remember in the 80s
there was like where's the beef right
right that's kind of like a meme yeah it
took everyone that's in everyone stops
yeah so I'm not
what evening
mm
like I I think that the values that we
hold important now there's gonna shift
you know and it hits been shifting you
know like people still buy Hummers you
know and I think we're going to get to a
place where it's like a Hummer it's
going to be a chunk of metal that you
know someone will trade a gallon of
water for because they're thirsty and
there's no gas without you know I mean I
think it's gonna be that kind of huge
shift where the things that we think are
valuable now are going to be worthless
and the things that we think are not
really valuable right now like land and
water are going to be like you need that
to live
the whole complete shift in what people
find valuable I think it's coming
of currency
I well I mean I I think that's a very
distinct possibility that yeah there
could be it's going to be like goods and
services are going to be exchanged for
good other goods and services I mean it
seems like there's always going to be
some kind of place for money because
that's how you that's how you do it you
know but I think what we're in now it's
so artificial that it's gonna pop you
know and it's been a people are gonna
realize hey this is a piece of paper and
what can I do with a piece of paper
can't heat it you can cover yourself
with it you know so I mean yeah you know
the money is just an idea it's not
something that's real so I mean I think
that that's gonna be a factor and how
people think because they're gonna
realize this is a this is only worth
what a piece of paper is worth which is
they're not really anything so you know
I mean I don't know exactly how it's
going to come down but it seems like all
money into hundred-dollar bills
it can't do anything for you really does
it happen trinsic value unlike a coat or
glass of water you know that stuff a
glass of water can save your life
you know our code can save your life
we're a hundred dollar bill can
[Music]
mom let's see I don't think I really
learned from youtubers because that's
not I'm not doing like what all these
other people are doing I was just like
I've been making videos since the 80s
and you know I just it's all soft pot I
started on like the oldest formats that
they had a videotape I am when YouTube
came out I was like oh that's me you
know what I mean so I was just backing
up my hard drive - when I started
uploading videos and wasn't trying to
get noticed or get attention I was just
doing this for my descendants you know I
wanted my descendants to see what I was
like and and all that so I didn't really
pay the YouTube game and when when I
went viral then I kind of started seeing
like oh this is how it works and this
you know didn't mean I was a conscience
of like an audience or you know there's
a whole different game I'm so different
than all the other youtubers you know I
mean I have a video with no one in it
right so yeah it's all different for me
[Music]
once that you saw
well probably what am I I mean how it
works for me is like they're my friends
first and then I go start watching them
because I meet them at these things and
like seven days after I started to go
viral this guy came out from LA and he
was like brother but one of my neighbors
is my friend and he made a video of me
and he kind of like he started getting
big on YouTube because I mean and and
but he's huge now he's got like you know
half a million subscribers I don't know
how much that macaroni he's my buddy but
I mean it's my my experience and I
relate to is so different than everyone
else who's had success on YouTube yeah
yes I'm not I'm not trying I don't want
I don't want this I just I'm doing and
it's just the fame and the recognition
is a side effect of that
oh I wouldn't be here and would be I
wouldn't be at this conference but I
mean my whole life is does not change I
have a farm you know I'm working my farm
and it's like okay so I travel you know
to do these conferences from time to
time and I do a lot of interviews but
99% of my life is exactly the same as it
was I wasn't ever going to change
I think yeah I grow a lot of my own food
[Music]
so here's the thing all right I don't do
recipes I it's like I create you know
what I mean
I don't measure anything I just roast it
together it's like it's good this is
what I got you know this is what's been
up all right now this is in season I
just throw it together and
most of the time it's not really good
not all the time but most the time it's
like yeah and he I can never make the
same thing twice it's just not my
function you know I'm just like this
free-flowing artist that's just like
throwing [ __ ] all over and I like to
make salsa especially if I have fresh
stuff and then I have this I have this
mulberry tree that gives us amazing
berries so I make a lot of stuff with
that I make teas I make all these kind
of fruit fruit teas and stuff I have all
kinds of herbs and mints and stuff like
that and I I make really good drinks and
then no I'm not but just like tea and
stuff you know and I'm all mixed fruit
in it what else I make a lot of stuff
with eggs because I you know I have a
grow eggs so I
and I think the best things are stuff
that come right off your farm you know
if you can just grow something and beat
it right then it's really it's different
it's most people have no clue what
that's like to grab something off that's
growing and eat it right then it's
different it's it's better it's
different and it's better and most
people don't know it you know they're
missing 70% of what there's there
because it's it's such a different
experience to eat something that's alive
sorry you missing out you get a farmer
like me we were going to a slushee over
there
[Music]
you see I mean I make a lot of songs so
you know I'll just get the tomatoes from
my yard and I have all these herbs and
I'll just make that stuff and it's like
whatever's whatever is coming you know
I'll just turn it into salsa just eat it
with with chips or tortilla chips or
something like that yeah I mean
so but I just really bad it like
following directions written directions
and measuring stuff I don't I don't
I just yeah and then I'll taste it I
thought oh that tastes good or I can
tell oh it needs a little bit of this so
different I think different
[Music]
quite a bit I mean
there was a famous actress who did a
double rainbow song and I was like oh
that's awesome you should come and film
what he had filmed a version of it here
they came and she's like a real popular
actress and she kept in my front yard
and then I got a lot of people who like
they follow my videos they watch them
and they're like oh it's so awesome
there and they come and visit me they
they cop out with me or we go into
somebody together so it's it's it's
something that happens quite a bit but I
think a big part of it is that that's
who I am anyway like I host people from
all over the world on my home through
couchsurfing and wolf and so like my
home has been something where people
just come to it's kind of like a
destination you know
it's it's a destination because it's
close to you somebody and people want to
go there anyway and like my place makes
it like convenient and easy to do so
people feel safe
oh yeah the couchsurfing has a binding
reference system so whoever comes and
and stays with me they get to leave a
reference and I can't I can't change
that reference so it's like you you can
ahead of time know what it's gonna be
like to come and visit me because you
can read what other people have said
about it like Yelp yeah it's like that
yeah so it's like I mean it it gives you
kind of like protection both from
people's visiting you and the people
visiting someplace they kind of know
what they're getting into because you
know people are going to say what is you
know they're not
they're not going to say you know
something that's not true because it's
going to come back on Park will stuff
you